for a long time now elevators have been
well boring
you get on you press a button find
awkward ways to avoid eye contact
and get out even finding stock video
footage of them
varies between dole and kinda creepy
unless of course you're watching them on
television
elevators on screen really waver between
the comedy of awkward social
interactions
i'm having a baby and the terror of
claustrophobia or a sudden plunge
[Music]
in reality though from a safety
perspective they're really the most
boring form of transportation around
they're safer than cars stairs and
lately even flying
but now elevators are getting a lot of
attention for the ways they encapsulate
the fears and anxieties that arise in
cities during the age of coronavirus
and it's no surprise that the very first
coronavirus themed horror movie
is set in an elevator you understand
that there's a virus going around
in this building but elevators actually
have a long history of adapting to our
fears and anxieties
and if we want to return to normal life
in urban areas elevators will once again
need to design themselves towards being
well boring
[Music]
yeah can you hear me yep i'm rolling on
my phone
i'm gonna clap so it sounds like you
dove pretty deep into elevator culture
uh now that you know so much about it do
you
do you miss them at all i mean yes and
no
i i feel really lucky to to live in a
walk up
and not be one of the millions of people
around the world who use them to get up
and down
their high rise apartment buildings but
i also kind of associate elevators with
like the sense of purpose
of an office and going into the office
which i
which i do miss what makes elevators
such a concern
in the time of coronavirus so many
things jump out
immediately all but the fanciest and
most high tech
require you to interact with potentially
germy surfaces
to operate they pretty much all present
the risk of other people
crowding into claustrophobic space at
any given moment
and i'm sorry to say that even empty
elevators could potentially
harbor infectious pathogens the science
on just how dangerous elevators are
is still being determined it's unclear
how many coronavirus cases can be linked
to elevator rides specifically
and experts say there are riskier places
like crowded subways and workplaces
still a lot of people are taking extra
precautions
building managers are laying down
intricate floor stickers to choreograph
riders that they're facing in different
directions
you have some buildings that are
recommending or really urging everybody
to wear a mask while they're inside and
others that are even encouraging people
to
keep their mouths shut while inside
helpfully enforcing that existing norm
of awkward silence
and then of course you've got some
people who are just plain opting for the
stairs
but any modern city needs elevators to
function and taking stairs
isn't an option for everyone especially
not for people with disabilities or
those who live in skyscrapers
while there may be different options to
move horizontally through a city
there's really only one way to move
through it vertically elevators are
responsible for the shape of modern
cities
over the past almost 200 years you see a
direct link between
the evolution of elevator technology and
the height of skyscrapers
even now the biggest structural height
constraint in today's super tall
skyscrapers
is the weight of elevator cables without
an elevator
you could not have built higher
buildings than let's say
six storeys because no one would have
climbed up seven or eight or 10 or 20
stories without an elevator
this is professor andreas bernard he
teaches cultural studies at the
university of lundberg
and he literally wrote the book on
elevators safety
and the history of elevator is
intertwined totally
because if the elevator should be a
absolute standard part
of the new high-rise buildings it had to
be hundred percent
safe while various forms of hoisting
things upwards
had been used for thousands of years it
was the late 1800s that the modern
elevator takes shape
if you now um google the history of the
elevator you will always find
one crucial event where everybody says
this was the most important event
in the early history of elevator and
this is the invention of alicia otis
who invented some brakes in 1855 which
prevent the cabin from falling down when
the rope was torn apart
when they gained the monopoly in
producing elevators around 1900
reinvented the history in their sense a
few years after the invention of this
brake technology
elevators were kicking off high-rise
buildings all over the world
and as cities became taller and denser
elevators soon ran into more perceived
safety concerns as well
it's pretty interesting if you study the
early history of claustrophobia
around 1880 then you realize that all
the early cases of claustrophobia which
shaped this disease
took place in elevators so the elevator
was kind of the
paradigmatic urban place
for this new disease soon some elevators
would adapt to this new anxiety
i was very surprised that the glass
elevator was a big fashion
around 1910 1920 and this was a reason
for that to make things
transparent less claustrophobic so the
glass elevator would be a design
decision
to make the elevator more friendly
even now elevators often have mirrors or
reflective surfaces inside that gives
you an illusion of space
going down in the elevator there are a
lot of visual and acoustic
phenomena which should help people that
this time of the ride
gets over very fast and that brings us
to elevator music
or muzak the muzak company sold this
background music
which promised to help increase worker
efficiency in factories
or have shoppers linger a little longer
in department stores
but it became most iconic as a method to
soothe elevator riders
and it's often played for a laugh in
films elevator music didn't have the
impact or the necessity to be
artistically sophisticated or to be
complex
it just had the mere impact to get this
30 seconds of the elevator ride
being over as quickly as possible but as
this muzak attempted to make it
feel like the elevator ride was shorter
modern-day elevators had turned to
algorithms to actually reduce travel
time
and boost efficiency i think elevators
continue to evolve and change
this is john clarin from physic group
the largest producer of elevators in the
americas
so if you think about a typical elevator
experience it's pretty simple
you have an up and down button outside
the elevator you choose that
you and any other user that may need to
ride the elevator at that time
gets on you select your floor and it
naturally just
rises up or down to arrive at those
floors in series and in order and drop
off and add
riders and for the most part on simple
buildings with normal traffic flow
those systems can work just fine and
they do all over the world but operating
the same type of system in large
buildings with many people
who want to get places quickly can be
fraught that's why a growing number of
modern buildings
utilize behind-the-scenes software that
helps direct the largest number of
people
to the most efficient route possible so
you might have experienced this if
you've
walked into a new skyscraper recently or
at least the before times
you select your floor outside the
elevator or you tell the security guard
where you're going
and an elevator is dispatched directly
to you and other people who are heading
to the same place
the efficiency grows tremendously it's
about a 30 to 40 percent improvement in
overall elevator system efficiency
but currently packing the most amount of
people into elevators
doesn't really make sense as the world
begins to recover from the kobit 19
pandemic
and office buildings begin to reopen
elevators again need to adapt
to deliver those passengers as safely as
possible
so the experts mostly urge the same
precautions you're hearing
for other kinds of spaces try to avoid
pushing the buttons with your hands
don't touch your face wash your hands
afterwards and do try to wear a mask
both for your own protection and for
other people and try to ride the
elevator alone
if you absolutely can't make sure other
people inside the car
are wearing a mask especially if you're
going to be in there for a while
and while limiting the number of
passengers drastically hurts the
efficiency of elevators in large
buildings
john explains that the same
software-based elevator system
can actually help encourage social
distancing we reprogram those algorithms
we adjust those algorithms
so it doesn't direct to load to the max
efficiency and capacity
but instead it loads it to obviously
fewer fewer users
so let's say eight people all want to go
to the 11th floor instead of an elevator
being dispatched to move the most amount
of people the fastest
two elevators can be sent and encourage
socially distanced travel
but as you might imagine this slow down
in efficiency could easily create
concerns
over crowded lobbies and that's where we
need to look at
traffic data and that's where the
elevators can also tell us
where it had been in the past in terms
of usage and volume
and we can help our customers make those
adjustments to the algorithm
so they can focus on safety first and
social distancing first
but balance that and stay ahead of the
the potential
traffic congestion that might be coming
elevator companies are eager to sell
these upgraded services to property
managers
as well as new hardware solutions like
kick buttons and uv light
to help disinfect not only the cabin but
to help in air purification
the only issue they're expensive it
might surprise you to hear that elevator
companies are not hurting quite as much
as you might expect
it seems stock market investors have
been putting their stock in a lot of the
new
technology services and improvements
that these companies are
increasingly selling plus people in
residential buildings are always going
to need to be able to ride
and while many have gotten inventive
with their solutions for elevator travel
the maintenance of these elevators have
left many with severe outages
while large employers and luxury
skyscrapers might have no problem
upgrading to the elevators the future
there are also plenty of tall buildings
where elevators are essential
but where they might not even be
functioning take for example
some of the towers in new york city's
public housing stock
broken lifts in some buildings have
forced people into stairwells
or even left them trapped while extended
outages
have rendered social distancing a
laughable fantasy
and when only one elevator is
functioning inevitably tired residents
crowd aboard
meanwhile people with disabilities are
left with little recourse
while elevators were relatively mundane
only a few months ago
it was really over a century of
innovations that made it possible to
think of elevators as boring in the
first place
and as these city-making machines must
again change for the sake of safety
they also offer a lens into the
socio-economic differences
of urban life and the way they relate to
the big socioeconomic disparities
in the coronavirus risks imagine a
luxury skyscraper that's housing
hundreds of residents in a small space
thanks to high-tech contact-free
direct dispatch elevator technology
those residents might be able to get to
their cloud-like abodes without ever
coming into contact with anyone else
but that's not true necessarily for
low-income residents
who in addition to dealing with broken
elevators are also more likely to be
going into work riding crowded trains
and
sharing poorly ventilated homes with
other people
as we know from case data it's lower
income people of color
and people with pre-existing health
conditions who are at highest risk for
chronovirus in many of our cities
so if we're thinking about elevators as
a problem to solve
in this new age of health risk and
health anxiety
it may be worth focusing first on the
riders who are most affected
you